Health officials in Haiti say they are
running out of medical supplies to treat
cholera patients the latest outbreak has
killed at least 175 people but thousands
more are suspected to be infected and
economic and political crisis in Haiti
has made the situation worse among those
most affected by cholera are children
like those in our next report
has just lost one of her children to
cholera now she's fighting to save her
seven-month-old daughter also sick with
the same disease
my son passed away during the night with
diarrhea and vomiting so he's gone I
don't have anything in the house the
neighbors brought me some things
Haiti has been hit hard by the outbreak
thousands have been hospitalized
and a lack of resources means not
everyone can survive this treatable
illness
the government does not have enough IV
because it was not prepared to treat so
many people they all have diarrhea and
need hydration solutions
they need beds
violence crushing poverty and Street
blockets by armed gang members are also
preventing access to Safe Water in
health clinics
the situation has prompted the U.N to
launch an appeal for nearly 150 million
dollars
but it is not only the Caribbean island
nation that has been affected in 2021
and this year several countries in
Africa and Asia were hit by cholera
outbreaks an epidemic in Syria that
started in August has led to infections
spiking in neighboring countries
including Lebanon
in October poverty stricken Lebanon
reported its first case in 30 years
the rising number of cases pushed the
country to launch a cholera immunization
Drive
but the World Health Organization has
warned of a worldwide shortage of
Cholera vaccine
leaving thousands at risk of losing
their lives unless help comes soon
let's bring in Jennifer Higgins here for
more she's with the International Rescue
committee and her work focuses on Syria
thanks for being with us Ms Hagan's
cholera is spreading in different parts
of the globe including the Middle East
how serious is the situation in Syria
thank you very much for having me here
today and I think it is really vital
that we're discussing this topic of the
growing Global crisis of Cholera and
this cholera outbreak especially in
Syria is really just an additional layer
on what is already an acute and
protracted crisis it's the first cholera
outbreak that we're seeing in Syria in
over a decade with the last one reported
in 2009 and until the 17th of November
we've now had a recorded 35 000
suspected cases with 92 deaths with
specifically the northeast of Syria
being the most affected and it's very
difficult also to really be sure that
we're getting a clear estimation of
really what the numbers are especially
in areas like Northwest Syria
it's just very hard to gauge customers
because of the varying responses and
leveling and the provision of healthcare
we've also now as you've reported in in
your piece just now had cases confirmed
in Lebanon and several also in Iraq
showing how this is really just a much
bigger issue more regionally as well as
globally and especially in rural areas
of Syria what's kind of been at the
heart of this specific and current
crisis is that the piped water supply
really isn't meeting the basic needs of
the population and many are left looking
for alternative sources of water and
this is because of after a decade of
conflict as you can imagine there's been
a real breakdown in both the scarcity of
water but also the infrastructure that
provides water and this pushes many
communities to have to resort to find
other places
I wanted to uh ask you about vaccines
because the who as you know is warning
that there's uh soon going to be a
global shortage of Cholera vaccines is
that likely to affect Syria and the
surrounding countries you've mentioned
yes indeed and the who has more warned
and there is currently a limited Global
Supply of the oral cholera vaccine and
this is due to the multiple ongoing
crisis and because we have this bigger
Global issue it does mean that there is
a severe limitation on the number of
doses and supplies that can be available
to Syria and this is combined with
severe funding gaps for the health
sector as well as limited existing
medicines and also human resources and
Health Care provision and for people to
be able to respond to an outbreak such
as this
so vaccines are in short supply for
treating cholera what else can be done
to contain a cholera outbreak and and
treat people who are infected
yes really at the heart of Colorado
prevention is really treating the source
and in this case uh we have identified
that the source of the current outbreak
was originally the Euphrates river and
but this is obviously spread now because
of migration of people Etc and because
of the limit
did Healthcare infrastructure so we at
the International Rescue Community have
really been working to identify source
and then also working on prevention and
also protection so it's really important
and we have been working to train
clinical staff and also community
healthcare workers on case and
management on detection and also on
providing the medicines available to be
able to treat the cases such as oral
rehydration therapy or zinc tablets and
doing really house to house Community
level based intervention
Jennifer thank you for that that was
Jennifer Higgins from the International
Rescue committee